[Music]
when the coronavirus shut down public
transportation and gyms
americans returned to a trusted classic
the bicycle
in march leisure bike sales increased by
121 percent in the us
by april bike shops across the country
were cleared out of inventory
at no point did we ever satisfy demand
and that demand is still holding strong
but bike companies are facing a problem
a shortage of bikes
this whole shelf right here all the way
back to that side of the warehouse is
usually stacked with bikes
and now there's nothing we visited two
bike shops
one in la and one in arizona to see how
they're keeping up with this
unprecedented surge in demand during
typical times
we have bikes in stock we could ship
them the bike that same day
that's mehdi the founder of state
bicycle in tempe
arizona usually he sells 30 to 40 bikes
a day
but now he's more than tripled his daily
orders to a hundred and fifty
metis bikes are made in taiwan and china
in
january and february right around the
lunar new year all bike suppliers really
were shut down
for at least four weeks then coven 19
shut down the factories for an
additional month through february
that happened just before demand for
bikes started to surge stateside in
mid-march
only a couple weeks later we were
completely sold out of bikes
even though bike shops were deemed
essential businesses medi still had
trouble
bringing new bikes in production times
are
getting longer and longer and that's
why we're seeing such a shortage of
bicycles still
over in los angeles adam mcdermott had a
similar story
his company linus bike was wiped clean
of its bikes
we immediately sold through all our
inventory and was just like waiting for
the next container and by the time that
next container arrived it was already
completely sold out
adam and his business partner chad
kushner started linus bikes back in
2007.
customers can buy their 50s
french-inspired city bikes
starting at 400 online our web traffic
increased by like 150
like every sector that we sell through
we're
seeing you know 100 increase in revenue
built in taiwan the bikes are sold all
around the world
but we stopped by the semi valley
warehouse in l.a
we're down to like kind of just the bare
minimums here
if we could just get more product that's
really what we're facing right now
from his venice beach shop not too far
away adam's team would normally sell
wheels to walking customers
meaning they could buy a bike and take
it home that day
but since the pandemic this isn't an
option
inventory supposed to last us the entire
year we were selling this in a matter of
months
so at like peak in july
we were back ordering for some models
all the way to february
which is insane for us linus went from
selling 1200 units a month
to about 4 000. now it's taking the
company nearly double the time to
produce a single bike
to keep up with demand both companies
had to get creative
we quickly went to a pre-order method
and
started ramping up our production
overseas
medi also put a cap on the number of
bikes each of his 300 dealers could sell
in order to prevent larger shops from
eating up all the
inventory and kind of taking away
availability from some other shops over
at linda spikes
when covert broke out new jersey where
our other warehouse is
the picture looked much worse there for
new jersey and new york so we diverted
all
inventory to the west coast just because
it seemed like this warehouse
will keep operating so we're doing all
our shipping from the west coast it's
it's much bigger expense but at least we
knew this this
warehouse would be functioning
adam's also working on a new kind of
inventory
we just introduced e-bikes they're just
landing now so they're not even
available we're just
we're still pre-selling them and those
range from about two thousand to three
thousand dollars
it's really massive kind of change it
became a business
of of managing inventory and trying to
allocate inventory
where we can get the bike to the
customer how we can like keep one
customer happy and not lose another
customer
if we had bikes in stock that we could
send to someone
same day i could only imagine sales
might be up
10x or more linus doesn't anticipate
getting many of its popular bikes back
until
2021 i think it's really key not to rest
on this crazy demand that is temporary i
know it's temporary in some form
i think if a business just kind of
expects it or assumes it
like you'll pay for it later my advice
for any other
small business owner out there try to be
as agile and flexible as you can in
order to adapt and survive
for both companies the biggest surges
happened in cities
where residents traded in crowded trains
for bikes it's portland
new york brooklyn chicago los angeles is
a big market
people just feel a lot more comfortable
commuting by bike versus
subway trains or buses now and the
demand for two wheels
isn't expected to let up we think demand
will hold into
2021 with so many more riders
experiencing their cities on bikes
the future of american cities might
actually transform as well
more and more people are going to look
to commute via bike which is obviously
awesome for the environment we love to
see that and who knows
maybe the next lance armstrong or the
next tour de france winner
has gotten on a bike during this
pandemic and
several years time we're going to kind
of see the next great american
road cyclist come out of this